and initiate sequencing memories are
made of this what is this place I'm
sorry to be the one to tell you this but
you got yourself killed at rst we'd
rebuild the most important assets in the
US military soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced with the technology in veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger you will heal
you instantly porridge
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going I got unfinished
business
man who murdered my wife
oh that's not good all right shutting
down
and initiate sequence okay who is the
next target for elimination
these are made of live tell me do you
remember anything do I know you guys I
don't think so
I've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
sure about that
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
I feel like I just hurt this is that
clintus MVP
[Music]